Redek, on a mangé quoi ce midi déjà ?
Du rôti à la courgette et à la fraise
Mûre
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que je me demandais le truc des 5 fruits et légumes, là
Quand ils disent 5 fruits et légumes
C'est 5 fruits ET 5 légumes ?
Ou c'est 5 les deux ?
Genre ça peut-être 5 fruits et 0 légume ?
C'est une bonne question, mon bon Cyrus
J'en sais rien
Commence déjà par bouffer ton poireau ça t'en fera déjà un
Et en parlant de poireau ! Il est où le seigneur bordel ?
Ca fait presque 1h qu'on attend, là !
Dis donc c'est pas un peu limite ça ?
Nan mais c'est par rapport au fait qu'on attende... T'sais le poireau... Poireauter... Poireau...
Voilà c'est...
Ah ouais... Il a vraiment un humour de merde
Oh exactement... Ned Stark il nous aurait jamais fait attendre comme ça !
On est d'accord !
T'es un peu un lèche-cul, toi nan ?
(Générique de GoT merveilleusement bien fredonné)
Nan pas du tout, je dis juste qu'on va pas se mentir : tout le monde l'aimait, Ned Stark
Il était gentil, fiable, aimait les gens autour de lui, il prenait les bonnes décisions
Bah du coup c'est sur, les gens l'aimaient
Je pense qu'on peut même dire qu'il était bon
Ouais c'était un bon gars
Nan mais je veux dire, bon, moral, quoi
C'est à dire qu'il place sa morale tout le temps au dessus de tout. Et dès le début il enchaîne les impératifs
Genre, par exemple, quand il dit qu'il faut toujours décapiter un déserteur
Voilà
Ou quand il dit qu'il faut jamais mentir à son roi ?
Exactement
Ou alors quand il aide Merry et Pippin parce qu'il a merdé avec l'anneau ?
Retiens surtout que l'attitude de Ned on peut la lier directement à Kant, parce que Kant il connecte l'Etat et la morale
Pour lui, l'Etat il est moral parce qu'il doit permettre l'action moral en lui donnant les possibilités pour qu'elle advienne
Grâce à un cadre, comme des lois par exemple
D'accord ! En fait il base toute son idée de la souveraineté sur son idée de la morale
Et on voit où ça l'a mené ! Il en a perdu la tête !
(Rires gracieux et poêtiques)
Nan mais c'est vrai, la morale de Kant elle se fait à-priori. Sans prendre en compte le contexte, les aléas, certaines intentions
C'est complètement déconnecté du réel
Mais c'est clair
Il aurait jamais dû devenir la main du roi
Le brave homme, il avait juré allégeance aux dieux, au roi et aux pauvres
Mais si jamais les trois veulent pas la même chose, bah c'est fini
Ouais. Ben en fait le Kantisme a les mains pures mais il a pas de mains, quoi !
Oui alors c'est Péguy qui a dit ça, hein
J'allais le dire
On est loin du grand Tywin Lannister
(Générique)
Tu vas pas encore nous faire l'éloge de sa façon de gouverner !
Et pourquoi pas ? Tu vas le blâmer parce qu'il a des manières qui plaisent pas à tout le monde ?
Mais c'est pas ce qui compte
La fin justifie les moyens !
Ce serait pas une idée du conseiller Machiavel, ça ?
Je sais...
J'allais le dire
C'est vrai que c'est efficace
Et pour le coup, l'efficacité, on a l'impression que y'a que ça qui compte !
Je me rappelles de la fois où Tywin voulait marier sa fille Cersei à Ser Loras Tyrell, et son fils Tyrion à Sansa
Evidemment aucun des deux n’était d'accord, mais c’était la bonne chose à faire pour garder le contrôle sur le royaume
Après c'est complètement immoral d'imposer ça à ses enfants
Ca doit faire bizarre...
Tyrion et Sansa, quand même
Ouais, enfin Tywin il va pas laissr la morale limiter ses actions
Ce qui compte pour lui c'est pas qu'une action soit bonne ou mauvaise. Ce qui compte c'est qu'elle serve le royaume
Et donc le prince
C'est ça ! Il faut que celui qui gouverne ait les mains libres. Quitte à être un beau salaud !
Craint par le peuple, en plus
Est ce que c'est vraiment ça la meilleure manière de gouverner ?
Est ce que la meilleure manière c'est pas plutôt celle de Daenerys Targaryen ?
(Générique)
Attends la femme ?! Khaleesi ?!
Elle a des dragons en même temps...
Même un enfant il pourrait gouverner avec ça
C'est pas un peu sexiste, ça ?
Il a dit quoi ?
J'en sais rien
Mais si vous l'êtes !
Nan mais c'est pas à toi que je parle...
Nan mais c'est vrai qu'elle est jolie !
C'est du sexisme, ça ?
Alors en fait on a oublié de tourner une séquence
Voilà, donc je me suis dit : autant vous dire concrètement qui dit quoi, comme ça vous loupez rien
Alors moi je dis : "c'est du sexisme ça ?" je le dis à Pierrot
Pierrot il dit "c'est à moi que vous parlez ?"
Moi je dis "non c'est au pape". Il dit "Mais on a pas de pape"
Et du coup...
Et ben ça reprend ici... Voilà...A toute !
On a pas de pape
Ah il est con... T'as intérêt à avoir une bonne raison de défendre sa manière de gouverner !
Ben c'est facile. Elle a réussi à accéder à la connaissance de ce qui est bon pour son peuple en contemplant le bien, le beau et le vrai
En fait elle a réussi à s'élever au dessus des opinions des uns et des autres pour savoir ce qu'il faut à son peuple
Et puis elle est blonde
Exactement
C'est à dire qu'elle est solaire, et qu'en plus elle maîtrise le feu, grâce à ses dragons
Son peuple, là, le peuple des dothrakis c'est des barbares, hein
Y'a une vraie différence entre la lumière du sage et les ténèbres de l'opinion
Putain tu dois en serrer toi de la pucelle
En fait elle guide son peuple
C'est ça
Et c'est exactement la pensée de mestre Platon
Elle est philosophe et il faut que le roi soit philosophe
Et il doit contempler la vérité, et ensuite l'appliquer au monde
Ouais enfin au début parce qu'après elle s'est rendu compte que ça marchait pas trop
Quand on veut imposer le bien absolu dans un bled, on est obligé de prendre et compte les coutumes locales
(générique)
Ouais c'est pour ça qu'elle a fini par accepter les arènes dans la cité de Meereen
Les combats à mort c'est une coutume locale
En fait les arènes sont pas souhaitables, les émeutes populaires non plus
Mais dans la cité de Meereen on préfère les arènes aux émeutes
Du coup les arènes sont nécessaires
D'ailleurs c'est à ce moment là que Tyrion arrive et se présente comme une vraie figure de conseiller !
Et Daenerys peut passer de la sagesse à la prudence
Ouais ! Elle a compris qu'en politique le bien né avant tout d'un contexte culturel bien défini
C'est un peu ce que dit le prince Aristote, non ?
Ca va... On allait le dire !
Ok donc en gros pour Platon, le bien vient d'en haut
Et pour Aristote il vient plutôt d'en bas, à travers la coutume, quoi ?
C'est l'idée
T'façons ça venait forcément d'un philosophe, elle aurait pas pû trouver ça toute seule
Tu m’énerves, je vais te couper ce qui te sert de sexe !
Ca ça fait une super transition pour parler de Lord Varys
(Générique)
Mais c'est qui déjà, lui ?
T'sais c'est le chauve, là. Celui qu'est un petit peu étrange
Qui tantôt aide les gens avec de bonnes intentions et tantôt les laisse crever sans scrupule
On dirait qu'il fait ça de manière un petit peu incohérente
Alors que pas du tout !
Bah développe
En fait ses choix sont très cohérents. Il a un but ultime, c'est la stabilité politique
Un peu comme le seigneur Pascal, finalement
Le rôle de la politique c'est de préserver l'ordre, et puis c'est tout
Attends l'ordre il peut pas se faire tout seul ?
Non, parce que pour Pascal, les hommes sont corrompus par le péché originel
En fait, dans une société, tout le monde a son avis, pourrait se lever et dire "je suis le chef et je suis légitime car je suis le plus fort"
Ouais genre La Montagne, quoi
Ou "je suis le plus intelligent"
LittleFinger !
Ou "Je suis le plus riche"
Donald Trump ?
Ouais enfin l'instabilité elle naît naturellement des légitimités qui s'entrechoquent
Et du coup c'est la guerre civile. C'est ça ?
C'est ça. C'est exactement pour ça que ce qui importe avant tout c'est le maintien du règne
Et ben Varys il est pareil. Il cherche toujours à éviter le chaos
C'est pour ça qu'il est pour la monarchie héréditaire : parce qu'on a déjà le souverain et que ça empêche l'écart de succession
En fait le roi c'est juste le fils de la reine, point
Et paradoxalement, c'est parce que ce choix c'est le plus arbitraire que c'est le plus juste
Ca permet d'éviter les guerres civiles qui sont les plus grands de tous les maux
J'avoue ! La légitimité du roi elle est à la fois artificielle et nécessaire !
Alors il se passe quoi quand Cersei elle a des enfants issus de l'inceste, ou quand Baratheon il a des batards à tour de bras ?
C'est les limites du modèle Pascalien
Ben du coup il faudrait faire quoi alors ?
Créer un nouveau personnage issu de l'union entre Lannister et Stark, Kant et Machiavel, Sansa et Tyrion...
Un nain roux, quoi !
Mouais... Ou alors mieux !
Que les gens s'abonnent à ma chaîne en cliquant ici, et à la vôtre en cliquant là !
Parce que vous avez une super chaîne sur la littérature, et vous venez de sortir un épisode sur le surnaturel dans GoT
Exactement et on explique en fait deux ou trois trucs sur le surnaturel en littérature à partir de GoT
Oui c'est ça. Et du coup c'est des trucs que tu peux ressortir dans des copies de français ou dans des after-work qui sont un peu chiants
Ca défonce !
Faudrait vraiment que les gens y aillent
Ah ouais, faudrait vraiment que les gens y aillent
(Sur l'air du générique de GoT) "C'est la fin de l'épisode sur Game of Thrones"
"Game of Thrones"
"Merc d'avoir re-e-regardé"
"Regardé"
"Suis moi sur les réseaux"
"les réseaux"
"Soutiens le projet sur Tipeee"
"Tipeee"